hey remember when they told you that the
covid vaccine was 100 effective at
stopping kovid and then five minutes
later they told you that you needed a
booster shot and then about five minutes
after that they told you that you needed
another booster shot well it turns out
you're going to need booster shots
forever but have no fear your friendly
neighborhood big pharma ceo is willing
to sell them to you
your company with your partner biontech
and modern of the other company have
both pioneered the use of messenger rna
which can easily be reprogrammed every
time the spiked protein of a coronavirus
evolves or changes do you think we're
going to get updated mrna vaccines every
season that'll be directed to each new
variation of the coronavirus and will we
have to take those shots every year
i'm almost certain about it and i say
almost certain because of course
regulators have the final say and all of
that but that's the beauty of mrna you
can adapt your vaccine just by changing
the sequencing which is a very minor
change either manufacturing or in the
properties of the vaccine safety or
efficacy but can make a huge difference
in the way that responds to the virus so
for this reason i'm very confident that
we will be able to respond very very
fast to every new variant
i am almost certain that you will have
to have the mrna vaccine every year the
hold up of course is the regulators but
we own the regulators you will get to
the shot every year it was only a matter
of time of course netflix
razors everything everything is moving
to a subscription model so it's no
wonder that vaccines are as well
i for one i'm just speaking for myself
here i will not be getting these annual
shots for covid i suspect many of you
will not be getting them either even
though the doctors are telling us to get
them even though these wonderful
charitable big pharmaceos are telling us
to get them the reason is that we no
longer trust the judgment of the people
who are telling us to get them that's
not our fault the people who lost our
trust have no one to blame but
themselves i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from scorpio who
says wait a minute i was reliably
informed that we were going to see a
rise in back alley abortions once
abortion was made illegal yet this girl
in the washington post had her twins
anyway it's almost like that's not
really a thing it's almost like that's
not really a thing and it's almost as if
the law
affects the way people behave it's
almost as if you might say culture is
downstream of politics sometimes isn't
that amazing and and we can do it we
here in the political community we can
pass laws we can get court rulings and
we can help shape the way that we want
to live we can do things for ourselves
we can even fix our car especially if
you go check out rock auto right now
head on over to rockauto.com and make
sure you write knowles in there how did
you hear about us box so they know that
we sent you i love rock auto they've
been with this show since the very
beginning they
have
wonderful auto parts truck parts whether
you're a pro whether you're a
do-it-yourselfer best prices anywhere
the catalog is so easy to navigate even
i can do it you know all of that buddy
of mine
he made a mistake the other day he did
takes a big man to admit he made a
mistake he goes in to a brick and mortar
auto parts store and he goes he just
needed some party he wasn't willing to
wait even the five seconds it would take
to order it online and get it from rock
auto
this part was supposed to be 150 the
brick and mortar store wanted to charge
him
400 dollars for the part so what does he
do
whips out his phone goes to that
rockauto.com easy to navigate catalog he
even shows them he says look look at
this part why i could get it for 150
bucks
do not go through all that rigmarole
that my friend had to go to just jump to
the very end go to rockauto.com make
sure you enter knowles they're in their
head did you hear about his box you can
get the brakes the shocks the carpet the
wipers the headlights the mirrors the
mufflers the lug nuts any part you need
rockauto.com right now is in the box
you'll thank me later
probably the most compelling reason as
to why we all need to get booster shots
all the time
is that everybody keeps getting covered
isn't it weird have you noticed this
everybody keeps getting kovid all the
time i've had covid three times at least
i've had covet three times where i had
symptoms i didn't get a test every time
but i did get a test sometimes and i
tested positive for covid
maxine waters democrat congress lady had
coveted twice in the span of i think two
months xavier becerra the biden
secretary of health had coveted twice
within the span of 26 days he had kovid
he recovered and then he got coveted
again
so in a way you would think this is an
argument for the booster shots except
ultimately it's not an argument for the
booster shots because all these people
have had their booster shots
justin trudeau mr castro's son up there
running canada
the guy had covid twice since january
he's got the vaccine he's got the
boosters
so
i do think we need to as we're examining
now where this virus came from
the crazy old conspiracy theory that it
came from the wuhan lab
that was discarded that was insane take
your tinfoil hat off
now the w-u-h-o is privately admitting
according to reports that that's true
we do need to ask ourselves before we
keep injecting ourselves with whatever
new nonsense big pharma comes out with
i think we need to ask some some more
basic questions about the virus where
did it come from what what was being
done with the virus in the lab and also
why does everyone keep coming down with
this damn thing we don't we don't get
the flu this much
we don't get other viruses this much you
get the flu once during flu season maybe
and then you don't get the flu anymore
how come you get covid twice in a month
it's a question well i don't we're not
allowed to ask questions we just have to
mindlessly inject ourselves
with these shots from big pharma that
immediately are proven not to do what
they say that they will do
why don't we trust the medical
establishment we don't trust the medical
establishment because they were wrong
about covet we don't trust the medical
establishment because they keep lying to
us
there's even a more basic reason and
this is beyond covid it's beyond the
vaccines it actually has to do with
the topic du jour that we can never we
always have to be talking about all the
time
in our culture for some reason and that
is transgenderism
transgenderism is a big part of the
reason why i don't trust the medical
community and the experts and the
healthcare system
it is i don't i don't trust doctors who
are affiliated with certain hospitals
and medical groups if those hospitals
and medical groups will perform gender
affirming surgeries and interventions
because i think huh
you don't even know that a man is not a
woman how can i trust your views on any
any other aspect of medicine
you you quacks are going in and pumping
little kids full of cross-sex hormones
and puberty blockers and chopping up
their bodies
why would i trust you about anything
else
regardless of what you think about the
vaccines and the virus and and and all
the rest of it if you if the if the
modern medical geniuses don't know the
difference between boys and girls i just
don't trust them i trust my plumber on
basic questions of medicine more than i
trust the modern medical establishment
now there is something we can do about
that
the the libs and the experts and the
technocrats always try to bully us and
they say you don't know anything about
transgenderism you don't know anything
about medicine you don't you don't know
anything about the science just listen
to the man in the lab coat just listen
to whatever dr fauci tells you just
listen to whatever that
hulking dude wearing a dress who is the
assistant secretary of health for
goodness sakes because we're living in a
monty python sketch just listen to
whatever
she tells you she's the expert and you
don't know anything and and you think to
yourself uh no
if the if if these people are the
experts
give give me the rubes
give me the know-nothings give me the
idiots because i suspect they know
something more
we can reign in the experts and the
technocrats in the lunatics
we can do that through legislation
we can we can do this through the
political rights whatever political
rights we still have left and some
republican lawmakers are doing just that
this is coming from the republican study
committee
congressman jim banks and representative
doug lamalfa and also tom cotton up on
the senate side they are sponsoring a
new piece of legislation that would
allow
individuals to sue
medical providers
for transiting them when they were kids
it's called the protecting miners for
medical malpractice act
this was created in response to the
biden administration pushing transiting
the kids and the puberty blockers and
the hormones and the
so-called sex change surgeries for
minors uh they're they're pushing this
law because they say that that these
kids who grow up and they become adults
and they regret having had these medical
experiments performed on them they need
to be allowed to seek justice in court
at some point on this show i'll have to
read some of the testimonies that are
proliferating all over the internet of
people who regret their transition
even though i don't even want to use
that word transition it makes it sound
so benign
makes it sound so simple oh yes well one
day i'm michael the next day on michelle
i transitioned transitioning involves
having your body chopped up and becoming
sterilized permanently usually and being
mutilated and
very often weakening your bones and
giving yourself all sorts of chronic
illnesses potentially giving yourself
osteoporosis all because of the quackery
of these radicals
and
people need to be given an opportunity
for justice
especially if this happens when you're a
kid if you're a little eight-year-old
kid eight-year-olds in some cases are
being put on these sorts of puberty
blockers
and then being put on cross-sex hormones
and then now the modern transgender
medical associations are encouraging
cross-sex hormones at 14 surgeries at
15. even the full-on surgery that
happens below the belt at 17.
you're a kid you you're below the age of
consent you're having experiments
performed on you you need to seek
you need to be allowed to seek justice
so how would this happen
sue the doctor sue the medical group sue
all of them i imagine i haven't read the
law i'm not sure that the text of the
law has even been released uh there
there probably has to be some kind of
a date before which you are not
permitted to seek
justice i don't know that you're allowed
to do this retroactively in a way it
seems kind of unfair to the doctors who
believe even these psychos even the
people who are chopping up kids some of
them might believe that they're
following the law and doing the right
thing and so
i'm not sure that this law would punish
them that might become problematic but
certainly if you say okay after this
date
if if you as a doctor trans the kids
you're opening yourself up to a huge
legal liability that at the very least
you've got to do that that would be a
huge huge victory
and you'll hear a lot of pushback from
the libs and a lot of pushback from the
doctors and a lot and they'll say this
is terrible you're stopping care you're
bullying doctors you're bullying the
experts and threatening them and
stopping them from performing the
surgeries and the interventions that are
technically legal today and you say yep
you're damn right we are you're right we
are going to use
any
legal means necessary
to stop this
because the reality of it is so
intolerable and so barbaric that no
civilized society should do it ever
speaking of
things that are
organic speaking of our life
you've got to go check out beam organics
right now go to
beamorganics.com knowles use promo code
knowles it's very important to get a
good night's sleep i think you know that
well did you know that poor night sleep
cannot just
screw up your next day it can cause
weight gain mood issues poor mental
health lower productivity some reports
say that sleeping less than six to seven
hours per night is linked to a reduced
white blood cell count white blood cells
protect our body against illness and
diseases fighting viruses bacteria and
more okay you need to get a good night's
sleep and that's why i'm introducing
beam
dream baby beam is the world's most
innovative functional wellness brands
with unique products for everything from
sleep to focus today our listeners will
get a special discount available for
beam's sleep product dream powder their
best selling hot cocoa it contains
premium ingredients triple lab tested
you wake up refreshed 98 of people
surveyed fall asleep faster when taking
bean dream 99
of people experience better sleep
quality just mix bean dream into hot
water or milk stir enjoy it before
bedtime it'll just be a nice little
delicious little treat and you will
sleep a lot better
you can get their their fabulous flavor
sea salt caramel dream powder it tastes
just like caramel drizzle on your summer
ice cream cone but with only 15 calories
how about that you're protecting
yourself against weight gain in more
ways than one if you don't love it you
get your money back guaranteed for a
limited time get up to 35 percent off
when you go to beam organics.com knowles
use code knowles at checkout
really really good legislation coming
out of the republican study committee to
stop these weirdos from transiting the
kids really bad legislation coming out
from squishy texas republican senator
john cornyn
john cornyn was the is the republican
who was anointed to negotiate with
democrats to give away our second
amendment rights and he did a bang-up
job of that
uh he's
now come to a compromise 13 other
republican senators have come to this
compromise with the democrats to give
away some of our second amendment rights
obviously the nra and other
gun owner lobbies are opposed to this
ordinary republicans are opposed to this
uh people who value our second amendment
are opposed to this but john cornyn says
well too bad we can't allow those
special interests to dominate the
conversation
on the nra strongly opposing the
legislation do you think that that will
sway any of the republican votes last
night i don't know you'll have to ask
them we were we worked very we worked
with the nra to listen to their concerns
but in the end i think they simply uh
they they have a they have a membership
and um and a and a business model that
uh will not allow them to uh uh to
support any legislation and so i
understand where they're coming from uh
but i think most people will not allow
any outside group to veto good public
policy
really really good public policy what
what good public policy you're talking
about this bill that would not have
stopped any of the mass shootings
that it's allegedly
supposed to address
that that really good legislation that
good legislation that opens up all sorts
of vulnerabilities for the government to
come in and take away the guns and the
second amendment rights of law-abiding
citizens that really great piece of
legislation it's not a great piece of
legislation it's a dumb piece of
legislation it doesn't do what the
democrats and the squishes are saying
that it would do it's just a way for the
democrats to push as best they can to
advance the same old gun agenda
completely separate from any of the
recent shootings
the same old agenda they've been pushing
for 50 years and so then the nra pushes
back and the nra is the boogeyman the
nra is the boogeyman for the left and
even sometimes the squish republicans
try to dismiss
the
totally normal concerns of of gun owners
and americans of all stripes who like
their constitutional rights and they'll
say oh it's just the nra
what do you think the nra is the libs
will call the nra the gun manufacturer's
lobby it's not the gun manufacturer's
lobby the nra exists for one purpose the
nra's purpose is to protect the second
amendment there are other gun lobbies
that do it as well that's what the nra
does i'm a member of the nra
i'm a lifetime member of the nra i
suspect a lot of the listeners out there
are members of the nra
the nra is about as american as apple
pie not only because americans love
their gun rights but specifically
because it is an association of people a
voluntary association that comes
together and influences politics alexi
de tocqueville when he wrote a democracy
in america
1831 he's traveling all around america
he notices this is one of the if not the
distinguishing feature about the united
states compared to other countries
around the world other countries around
the world when they're trying to get
political action accomplished they'll
send magistrates they'll send princes
they'll send all sorts of officials in
america instead of that we send the
association
the voluntary association it could be it
could be trade unions it could be
civil groups i don't know the lions club
it could be
in interest groups civic interest groups
like the the nra any of them that's
that's how america does business it was
true 200 years ago it's true today
not only can we let the nra shoot this
down we absolutely should and if this
these republicans had any moral clarity
any political clarity any backbone or
other anatomical features i know those
are those are very much in the news
these days they would go along with that
and they would they would reject this
ridiculous legislation the democrats are
admitting that this legislation is not
about accomplishing some great feat that
would stop the mass shootings in the
near future the democrats are admitting
it's just a first step it's just making
it easier to get more and more and more
of of the gun control agenda that the
dems have been pushing for amy klobuchar
said it yesterday
this bill is going to save thousands of
lives and this isn't everything that i
would have wanted to do i think chris
would say the same thing
but we had republicans that were willing
to come to the negotiating table and
while i would have banned assault
weapons at least 18 and 21 year olds but
what did they do they actually did
something that's going to save lives so
to start with something that's going to
save lives even if a particular
provision wouldn't have saved their own
babies lives
that is an act of love and generosity of
spirit that you hear from the families
of those that have lost loved ones
that's why we're moving ahead and i
think it actually paves the way in the
future to look at some of these other
provisions but if you do nothing and you
just go home then we've got nothing and
that's why it's so important to pass
this bill on a bipartisan basis
she's admitting two really important
things here
she says look this is just the first
step it's just paving the way it's going
to make it easier to get more of our
stupid agenda through and two yeah okay
maybe this wouldn't have saved
your baby's life
your community's life your life maybe it
wouldn't have
done the things we're saying it would do
but it'll save lives generally trust us
yeah jen no i know whenever you ask us
to to give an example whenever you point
to a specific case and you say will your
bill address this and we we have to say
no but
you know but generally it probably will
so anyway give us your guns give us your
rights
uh that's it's really important because
once we get this bill through we're
gonna work on the next gun bill
that's what we're gonna do
really really
bad
idea this by the way not only is there
no evidence this would save lives there
is evidence that this could cost lives
i'm i'm reminded it's an eerily similar
situation in the mid 1990s 96 or 97 in
the uk they banned handguns there was
a shooting at an elementary school i
believe and the uk decided to ban
handguns and then they measured what
happened six years later six years later
what happened to the murder rate do you
think it went down did this important
legislation save lives no the murder
rate went up the murder rate almost
doubled
would something similar happen here i
don't know is the legislation exactly
the same i don't know but can you amy
can you give me any evidence at all that
this would save lives and be worth
gutting one of our constitutional rights
one of our most basic constitutional
rights a constitutional right derived
from a natural right a natural right to
self-defense i don't think so
but the squishes go along with it the
squish republicans who think this is a
good idea
are just swamp creatures this is a
really good
test
for republican legislators are the are
you a republican legislator who knows
what time it is who talks to your
constituents who gets what's going on in
america or are you just a total swamp
creature and i'm i'm not even
impugning their motives here i'm just
observing the fact that
americans do not want gun control
the republicans certainly don't want gun
control the democrats might want gun
control but even the democrats don't
want gun control that much they don't
really care when you whenever you see a
poll of political priorities guns even
for the dems even for the gun grabbers
are pretty far down the list voters care
about the economy voters care about
immigration voters care about jobs but
they voters care about health care they
don't really care that much about guns
so what's the point of this
why are these 14 squishes on the
republican side going along with it
because people in dc really care about
guns and people in the media really care
about guns and people that think tanks
really care about guns and these are the
people that these swamp rats are
regularly socializing with and so they
they have a completely skewed view of
what americans really want you want to
know the clearest example of this of
this distinction this huge chasm between
ordinary americans and the swamp
creatures in dc
it's the it's the january 6th hearings
i'm sorry i need to i need to pronounce
that correctly it's the
january 6th january 6 the worst day ever
in the history
people in dc
care about
january 6th
people in america
could not possibly care less
i'm not wishcasting i'm not
living in my conservative echo chamber
i'm reading abc news i'm reading an abc
news ipsos poll
that asked
ordinary americans how closely are you
following the january 6th hearings which
are being aired
constantly in the lib media the lib
media are playing this thing ad nauseam
they're covering it in their newspapers
they're pumping it out through all of
their various communications channels do
you know how many americans are
following the january 6th hearings very
closely
less than 10
even with all of that even with the huge
weight of the media government big tag
propaganda machine behind the dems
behind the january 6th hearings
less than 10 of americans are following
this closely they do not care
the the wise politicians are going to
get that the wise politicians who are
going to help to shape the future are
going to be speaking to the interests of
actual american people not the
whining performances of liz cheney and
adam kinzinger and the democrats but i
repeat myself in the squish republicans
with republicans like those people who
needs democrats in the first place now
when you want to get
real information when you want to hear
about things that actually affect your
life and affect the american people and
are not merely uh being being promoted
by the swamp rats in washington dc
you've got to head on over to
dailywire.com
knowles that's the place to go
not slash shapiro not slash clavin not
slash walsh not slash jeremy not slash
anybody dailywear.com
knowles
you can sign up you can become a member
you can support us in this fight you
will save 25
if you go to that specific url
dailywire.com slash knowles we've got
backstage live at the ryman coming up if
you can't make it out to nashville to
see us in person you can stream it there
but you got to go to the daily wire
dailywire.com slash knoll save 25
we'll be right back with a lot more
the dc types are not going to be winning
any awards for their performances at the
january 6th hearings liz cheney she's
putting her heart and soul into this
performance adam kinzinger obviously all
the democrats and they're not going to
be winning any oscars okay
they're not persuading people that trump
committed some crime they're not
persuading people that there was an
insurrection the country almost
collapsed because of the horn hat guy
they're not convincing people even to
care they're not convincing people even
to tune in they're not very good
performers do you know who is
a great performer one of truly the
greatest performers of our age i was
reminded of this a couple of days ago
you know the man president coffee donald
trump he gets up there
he's giving a speech about some
completely unrelated topic and he he
brings up
joe biden's falling off a bicycle in the
most charming hilarious way possible
one of the greatest travesties
of all is to see a person in the white
house who
even after years of political experience
has absolutely no clue
how to be the president of the united
states and i hope he has recovered
because as you know he fell off his
bicycle today
no i'm serious i hope he's okay
fell off a bicycle
i make this pledge to you today i will
never ever ride a bicycle
i love the way he turns it there at the
end
like he's doing a comedy routine like
he's lighting up a cigarette next to us
you guys hear about this you guys hear
about the president falls off a bicycle
yeah yeah no he did he did he fell off a
bicycle and then you you you're waiting
for him if he were just an ordinary
politician
he would do one of two things he would
concern troll and he would get very
somber and serious and say no but really
really i am wishing him he's a good
family man
he's a good
especially the bidens quite a family a
good family man i really we hoped for
his recovery he would do that or he
would get really angry and
self-righteous and indignant and make
some political attack on him but trump
has this show business touch
so he's he lures you in he says yeah he
fell off a bicycle he saw that no he did
he did i hope he's okay i hope he's okay
and then he he turns it and makes a
self-effacing joke he's not even
boasting he's not bragging he's not
blowing himself up
he's making a joke about himself because
i'm never going to ride a bicycle you
look at me do i look like the kind of
guy who's going to ride a bicycle this
is something people never got about
trump they all they would see is the
bragging and the boastfulness and the
gold and everything and they think that
the guy's a total egomaniac and a
narcissist that's not quite true
yes he puts his names on the buildings
yes he refers to himself in the third
person
but he does have a self-awareness he
would frequently make jokes at his own
expense one time he was asked about if
he would have a beer and donald trump
doesn't drink and he said may no i'm not
i think i might be the only president
who can say he's never had a beer it's
probably the only good thing you can say
about me
he's making a joke that he's got these
sorts of other vices but but he doesn't
drink look at me do you think he was
asked once do you are you going to get a
pet in the white house you're going to
get a dog and he said no they're all
telling me i need to get a dog to be
more likable and you know that's just
what the president's doing i don't know
i don't think it's me i don't think it's
really me and it's it's not it was not
really him and no you can't picture
donald trump riding a
bicycle these little moments
do give me some pause for
2024. right now ron desantis is getting
a ton of play people are talking about
him as the potential nominee the guy's
amazing i don't i don't have a negative
thing in the world to say about ron
desantis he's a he's the greatest
governor in the country he might be the
greatest governor of a state that i have
seen in my lifetime he's doing a great
job so there's no wonder that he's
getting a lot of presidential talk
some other people are getting
presidential talk too pompeo is getting
some senator cruz is getting some nikki
haley was getting some i don't know that
she totally is anymore
there are other people who
who are out there as potential nominees
you can tell there are a lot of other
governors and a lot of other senators
who are trying to run for that as well
my hesitation on just saying okay
trump's old news let's move on is just
while all of us were paying a lot of
close attention to politics while all of
us
might love this governor or that senator
or this former cabinet official and
we're really tuned in we say well here
are all the reasons why so and so would
be a much better president than trump
while we're doing that
are we in our own little bubble here
do those other candidates do they have
the ability to reach as many people who
maybe aren't totally tuned into politics
who maybe don't follow all the latest
trends on twitter or whatever
can they reach people as effectively as
trump i don't know this is a totally
open question right now and trump does
come with a lot of baggage and i'm not
convinced that
whether because of his own faults or
because of the system that is completely
rigged against him i'm not sure that
donald trump will be allowed to be
president again
i'm not it's a totally open question but
it is something seriously to consider
the
trump has gifts
that are not that are not so easily
quantified
as some other politicians he's got he's
got aspects to him that are just sort of
ineffable that are just you don't you
don't factor them in as much but a
little joke like that the ability to
rile up a gigantic crowd the the star
power that the guy comes with
is valuable now all of that said
desantis
is not only beginning to challenge trump
in some places he's beginning to pull
ahead up in new hampshire
ron desantis is now beating trump in a
presidential poll there's a university
of new hampshire granite state poll
released on wednesday
desantis gets 39
trump gets 37 percent then pence nine
percent and nikki haley six percent so
pence and haley are
very very far behind
uh
but desantis and trump desantis is
leading trump by two points
then they did a general election poll
again in new hampshire
desantis versus biden
the poll says desantis wins by 1.4746
trump versus biden the poll says that
trump loses by seven points biden 50
trump 43.
so what does this tell you
it tells you desantis is in a really
really good position
it tells you desantis is doing all the
right things
and
it tells you that if if trump does want
to do this again if he's really serious
about running again and he's not just
using this as a
promise or threat to maintain his
influence in the gop he's going to have
to start getting aggressive
relatively quickly
he's going to have to start positioning
himself as the guy right now ron
desantis has relatively low name
recognition
that seems strange to you and i because
if you're listening to this show you of
course know who all the players are you
you know all the potential 2024 nominees
you know the governors you know the
senators but
a lot of people don't and a lot of
people know trump trump's been a
celebrity for 40 years
well that's not going to be true forever
the more desantis or whoever
don't forget these these people can peak
very early too and then new candidates
come up no one would have predicted
trump in 2015 2016. but right now
desantis is the guy so
the more desantis shows of himself
the more likeable he's going to be the
more name recognition he's going to get
the firmer he's going to be in those
polls and the craziest part of ron
desantis rise
is
he almost wasn't governor
this is something else that we forget
about and frankly actually trump was
important in helping ron desantis get
over the finish line in florida
desantis only won by 33 000 votes
it was desantis versus andrew gillum it
was desantis versus a guy who shortly
after the election was found in a hotel
passed out with narcotics around him and
a gay hooker passed out on the floor
okay that guy that guy was almost the
governor of florida
ronda santa squeaks by with 33 000 votes
he could potentially be
the next republican presidential nominee
he could potentially be the next
president shows you how important those
little votes can be
and and this really brings us to the
supreme court decision i've been on the
road i've been in la we've been filming
stuff for prageru i'm going up to the
reagan ranch later today i'm giving a
speech with young america's foundation
it's going to be a great deal of fun and
the only thing that has been at the back
of my mind this entire week is
when will the supreme court decision
come out
we got that leaked draft of the supreme
court decision
weeks ago we still don't know who leaked
it we still haven't gotten the final
decision yet we don't know what's going
to happen
whenever that happens that's going to be
possibly the biggest political news ever
to occur in my lifetime it will be it'll
be it'll be bigger and frankly more
surprising than the election of donald
trump
and it'll be some of the most
significant political news ever in the
history of our country
and it could hinge on one vote
it
it certainly will hinge on whether or
not trump won in 2016.
when people were making all of these
arguments in 2016
do we vote for trump or hillary or
even the republicans the never trump
movement on the republican side well i
don't know i can't he's just trump is
too crazy it's not worth it i can't i
can't bring myself to vote for him
one of if not the top argument for
voting for trump then was the judges
yeah maybe you don't like the guy maybe
you don't like the way he talks maybe
you don't like some of his policies but
we need to get those judges we're
talking about we're talking about
matters of life and death when you talk
about roe v wade we're talking about the
possibility of saving almost a million
babies a year from being killed
or at least opening the possibility to
save that number of babies if you get
rid of roe
well now we're seeing potentially the
fruit of that
and so i've been waiting on on my tippy
toes with just you know grabbing the the
table everyone's saying when is this
decision coming out in part for a really
basic reason i need to i need to
broadcast i want it in my show i want to
talk about it
and uh sweet little alisa was was joking
with me she said well can't you just
pre-tape your reaction to it
yeah you just you saw the draft of the
case you know a lot about roe v wade
we've all you know we we all know those
parts of the issue can't you just
pre-tape as if it already happened and i
said no
because
anything could happen right now it's not
just
okay we're waiting for the inevitable
they're gonna overrule row we have no
idea what they're going to do first of
all i'm not even convinced that they're
going to overrule it they're going to be
two parts to this decision one is the
court gonna uphold the mississippi
pro-life law
that i think is pretty much a guarantee
and then two will the court go further
and overrule roe v wade and planned
parenthood v casey or will the court try
to find some middle way where you uphold
the pro-life law in mississippi
but then you
you
allow the precedent of roe and casey to
remain don't forget planned parenthood v
casey which is one of the big
pro-abortion court decisions planned
parenthood v casey overruled parts of
roe v wade and and it did so it
overturned the frameworks of roe v wade
and it did so in this real technical
legal jargony way where it upheld the
fictional legal right to an abortion but
it
it changed the reasoning it changed the
arguments you could get something like
this
with the court
thomas is going to vote to overrule roe
alito is going to vote to overrule row
i hope kavanaugh and barrett and gorsuch
don't go squishy i hope that john
roberts doesn't
pull some shenanigans here
but but it could have you you could get
a decision where we don't even really
get what the decision is the court could
be intentionally obtuse the court could
be intentionally
uh
vague in their language so that they
hand down the order and we don't even
really know if row is overruled or to
what extent it is or how
anything
could happen now i think it would be a
huge huge mistake
if the court does not overrule roe i
know
what some of the court watchers and
potentially chief justice roberts are
thinking they're they're thinking we
need to preserve the institutional
integrity of the court roberts from the
beginning has tried to figure out a way
to pardon my expression split the baby
here and uphold the law but not over
rule row he's been trying because he
thinks that'll uphold the integrity of
the court we're past that now after the
leak after the attempted assassination
of brett kavanaugh after the incessant
protests illegal protests in front of
the homes of the judges
we're past
trying to mollify everybody
it may have been true before that the
way to preserve the integrity of the
court or at least to preserve the
general feeling of not uh complete anger
against the court would be to split the
baby here we're past that now the the
risk to the integrity of the court
comes from the people who are trying to
squish
the
greater risk
is is
going weak here in the same way that
when when you're driving
sometimes driving slowly is the more
dangerous option sometimes you need to
drive a little more confidently and
assertively sometimes you've got to put
your foot on that accelerator a little
bit more to do the safe thing in the car
to avoid
uncertainty to avoid i don't know
potential other cars that are driving in
a weird way sometimes you've got to be a
little more assertive sometimes the best
defense can be a good offense it's the
same thing here it's totally the same
thing here if the court squishes
you are sending a message to the worst
people in this country that if you
make threats
if you
intimidate judges families if you try to
if you threaten to kill the judges if
you threaten to riot and dox people
if you violate the norms of the court
and leak decisions
you'll get your way ultimately you'll
get your way it's a really basic it's a
really basic system of incentives
when you incentivize a behavior you get
more of it
that that would be
potentially a fatal blow to the supreme
court
if
if the court sends this message then
on ordinary decisions it won't matter
the court will just keep ruling and
people won't pay much attention to it
but on every
single contentious decision
you're going to get more protests
outside the judge's homes you're going
to get more assassination attempts and
you're going to get more mostly peaceful
rioting
you're seeing this still right now
outside of amy barrett's house there was
another group of of just lovely looking
little young women who spattered
themselves in fake blood and shrieked
outside of amy barrett's house where she
and her family live
so now that you put these outfits on
does it make you feel any kind of way
it makes me feel terrified
but also powerful
and like we're doing something important
because this is how a lot of women
this is what a lot of women are going
through people are actually dying and
bleeding out because they can't get a
safe abortion
and this is the terrifying visual of
what america is going to look like it's
the terrifying visual that children are
giving birth to children
they're being forced to against their
will
for those people fortunate enough not to
be watching those girls and just be
listening to it they covered themselves
up in fake blood they were holding
little babies little dolls of babies
they looked like something out of the
walking dead and
they're relatively young women and they
say
well in america now this is what's
happening women are bleeding out from
back alley abortions it's not happening
that's not happening at all
well that's what's going to happen in
america if roe is overruled no it's not
it's not true all of the lies about
thousands of women dying every year from
back alley abortions
that was just completely made up by the
pro-abortion movement that's that's not
true
even if they did have a point which they
do not
do these people look
like they've got their life together do
these people look like they've got a
good argument to make do these no do you
want to be with them do you want to be
protesting alongside them do you want to
be on their side of politics i don't
think so they're nuts they're they're
they should not be encouraged to protest
out certainly to protest outside of the
judge's homes which is illegal or
really anywhere else they
they need to be told no these shrieking
crazy
lying
young lunatics they need to just say no
no we're not going to do that you don't
get to do that you don't get to break
the law you don't get to keep killing
the babies
no you don't get to threaten the supreme
court
we're going to say no and then you're
going to go home and that's that
same issue with crime
right now the
chicago police department has just come
out with a new policy here's the new
policy so chicago which is basically
like downtown fallujah okay chicago not
not the nicest place to be walking
around at any time crime up through the
roof the police have decided that the
way to deal with the crime problem is to
stop
chasing suspects
i just want to add as an overview foot
pursuit policies have been part of law
enforcement for over a decade now
just because chicago pd is now
implementing a
permanent one the impacts on crime has
been studied and we can look back at
foot pursuit policies it's made officers
safer and it's made the community safer
in cities that's implementing this over
a decade so the expectation for us is
like bob mentioned what will learn and
be informed by our documentation and
review
of how to continue to enhance officer
safety as well as enhance safety of our
residents
in in that word salad that this
bureaucrat wearing a badge just said
did you did you catch the the gist of
what he's actually trying to convey
he's saying that if cops don't do their
jobs they might not be in as much danger
which i guess is true
you don't need studies for that they all
the libs always cite studies all of
which are are wrong
every single study i am willing to say
is wrong or at the very least is not
credible i just don't buy them i don't i
don't buy they because the libs don't
have any arguments from principle they
they just cite studies even when the
studies are completely irrelevant yeah i
guess it's true if a cop stays home he's
not going to be in as much danger as if
he's chasing a suspect
the community won't be safer chicago
won't be safer i really don't want
chicago politicians lecturing me on how
to have a safe community okay because
all all that this guy is suggesting
boils down to surrender if you surrender
to the criminals and you let them wreak
havoc in your community then
you won't have to deal with them
in that moment you will have to deal
with them because they're running your
community but it's preposterous
there's no
here's here's my study here i've got a
study i don't i don't have the
statistics on me right now but my study
is when you arrest the criminals they
don't commit as many crimes because
they're in prison how about that how
about that idea
i said well no we're so we're such
geniuses that we're not even going to
arrest them in the first place
that that does not make a lot of sense
that is a surrender and
look i want to i want to protect cops i
don't like that cops are in danger
obviously danger goes along with the job
i think cops are in
more danger
when you in the long run at least when
you allow crime to spread when you allow
crime to go unpunished even if these
specific cops say okay don't run don't
chase them go go run and hide say the
politicians in chicago
but what are you going to get that's
going to give you more crime and the
more crime you get
the bigger a target you've got placed on
cops the more the more incidents that
the cops are going to be called to to
say nothing of the terror that's going
to to be inflicted upon the ordinary
civilian residents of chicago
sometimes the safe strategy the safer
strategy is to get a little bit more
aggressive if we just arrest the
criminals and put them in prison and
deal with our
under-incarceration problem they always
talk about over-incarceration we
actually have an under-incarceration
problem
here's my study on that crime is going
up when crime is going up it means
you're not incarcerating enough people
sometimes the best strategy is to get a
little bit more aggressive
and all the studies in the world and all
the boring jargony technocratic talk
from politicians like that guy in
chicago
it doesn't change the realities of this
doesn't change the realities at all the
the
strategy from the political left right
now is just to to distract us all
the the strategy from the political left
is just to continue to
push the same old policies they've been
pushing for half a century at least and
use whatever's in the news as an excuse
to do it even if their policies have
nothing to do with what's actually going
on in our communities i saw a video
yesterday that is so
powerfully cringe inducing
that i i'm glad that i was able to get
my face fixed before this show because i
could have come on the show just sort of
my muscles all twitched it was so
incredibly cringe-inducing from
a left-wing activist who is singing and
rapping about how we need to take away
your gun rights we don't have time to
get to it today you will have to tune in
tomorrow that's going to be your little
your little carrot for tomorrow this
this truly i mean you'll need 24 hours
to prepare yourself anyway you know get
maybe get a massage get put some lotion
on your face so that you your face does
not get stuck in this kind of cringe
the
the shriekers
and the
the whiners and the
preposterous experts and the technocrats
and all those are the people who are
currently running our show when we tune
them out
that's not our fault that's their fault
when we tune out all these all these
supposed self-styled geniuses that's us
acting in our rational interest i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show